[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 123
over the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I'm mark Mandal and I'm here
with my colleague as always
Melanie work how you doing today Melanie
I'm good how are you doing mark I am
slowly still getting over this cold it's
not gone but they're ending illness yeah
pretty much it's been going around but
you're hanging in there I am and we have
some cool people coming to chat with us
today we do we are going to be talking
about quantum security quantum computing
security in particular and we're talking
with Nick and Adam which will be fun to
hear about but before we get into that
well dive into our cool things of the
week and of course as always we have our
question of the week that comes at the
end and the question this week is how do
I stream real time when I'm coding like
how do I do real-time coding I've been
doing that so I might have an answer I
think you might okay cool anyway cool
things of the week some may have heard
of an event called Google i/o and that's
coming up May 8th through the 10th done
it a few times now there's quite a
popular event that's in Mountain View
since tickets are out there will
actually be the opportunity if you want
to help do extended events and there's a
link will provide in the show notes
where you can apply if you wanted to
make it an official thing and we provide
resources on how to stream live the
actual event and organize with others
who are interested in watching so yeah
we will include that and that's coming
yeah and if you are not local like and
you want to go to an extended event
there's a map on the extended event page
it has a huge number of events already
set up and ready to go so if you don't
wanna go to all the trouble of setting
something up then it's probably one you
can go to alright and we also want to
announce apparently App Engine turned 10
yeah so there's a really great blog post
on the Google cloud blog just reflecting
on our ten-year app engine looking back
came back in time all the memories yeah
this is your life how do you feel about
that yeah exactly
so actually they've got a really nice
little interactive image that you can
click on and kind of see a different
time sort of big highlights about on
things I did not know this I'm just
clicking right now 2011 William and
Kate's Royal Wedding website on GAE hey
did not know that we're
part of the wedding somehow that's
awesome so yeah have a quick read it's a
nice nostalgia cool the other cool thing
in the week is that we wanted to mention
how stackdriver
APM and stack driver profiler two new
products that we have out there as part
of the stack drivers suite so the stack
driver APM is using stack driver trace
and debugger and they put that together
in the APM tooling to allow you to debug
applications while they're running
production without impacting years your
experience in any way which is huge and
always is a challenge that you're up
against especially in the DevOps space
but the new tool in this is the stack
driver profiler and that's letting you
profile and explore how your code
actually executes in production to
optimize performance and reduce cost of
computation there's one other thing to
that room include the blog post on this
there's an integration between stack
driver debugger and github Enterprise
and get lab and so that's adding to
their existing code mirroring
functionality for github bitbucket
Google Cloud repositories as well as
locally stored source code so lots of
great functionality for profiling and
debugging and solving issues that you
have in your production environment in
your code which is always necessary and
much needed especially in distributed
environments yeah and the profile of
makes pretty flame graphs yay pretty
flame graphs yeah that's what's
important and now and I got a nice
example of an endoscope posts actually
which I think are really nice if you
remember back to November of last year
we did a wonderful episode on smart
parking and IOT core with Brian granite
here
he talked all about event-driven systems
and using cloud functions and pub/sub
and datastore and bigquery and all that
stuff so he has written and we've
published on the Google cloud blog a
three pot series way he goes way into
the weeds on all the technical stuff
that they have done at smart parking to
create this system and how it's all
running and that stuff and if you
listened to the podcast previously it is
definitely written in a Brian granite
ear style I can hear his voice all the
way through it which means it's fun and
exciting and a really good read yes
definitely great all right mark let's go
talk with Adam and Nick let's do it all
right
on this week's podcast we are excited to
have Nick Sullivan who's from CloudFlare
and Adam Langley who works on Chrome
we're going to talk about post quantum
security or post quantum cryptography
thank you guys for joining you
yeah thanks for having us so Adam and
Nick can you take a minute and tell us a
little bit more about yourself and what
you work on Nick why don't you start
sure so I work at CloudFlare which is a
service that helps protect websites and
accelerate them as well as any sort of
service that's on the web and I'm
responsible for the cryptography team so
we look into different cryptographic
technologies to help protect traffic
between folks who are browsing the
Internet and web sites and web services
that they're gonna be visiting this
means making sure that it's confidential
making sure that this data is
authenticated great
I'm Adam Langley so I manage the team at
Google who is responsible for most
front-end cryptography so that means
cryptography between Google servers and
its users and mostly we work in Chrome
and obviously on our servers and then
also dipping in occasionally to Android
and wherever around the company that we
can be useful nice and so I know Adam
Nick and you have worked a little bit in
the past together and have worked from
the security standpoint for today's
interview of course we're diving more
specifically into quantum and post
quantum security can you guys give us a
little bit of an understanding of what
is quantum computing before we dive into
the security element of it so computing
as we have known it for decades now
since chewings time has all been based
on classical physics more or less
although down at the very know depths of
how a CPU is made there were quantum
effects what we're trying to build is a
computer that deals with ones and zeros
and you could have works out in theory
how these computers work in the eighteen
hundreds if you want it a quantum
computer is a computer that's you know
obviously not just made in the quantum
universe but uses effects of quantum
physics and it's difficult to convey
quite what that means but there are
certain problems where the ability in
quantum physics to have states that are
a mixture of ones and zeros and to use
the fact that in quantum physics
probabilities are the square root of
sums of squares rather
than the sums and things where those
abilities allow you to solve some
problems significantly faster and many
problems quite a lot faster nice
Nick was there anything you wanted to
add yeah so quantum computing is
something that involves as Adam said
quantum physics and quantum interactions
and the more classical way of thinking
about this is is you know the idea of
Schrodinger's cat where you have a cat
it's inside an enclosed region and it
can be in a superposition of ways the
cat alive or is the cat dead
so because you can't see it and you
can't interact with it quantum effects
allow multiple states of being to exist
simultaneously and the first time that
you actually interact with it or look at
it it immediately crystallizes as one
specific state whether you know the cat
is alive or the cat is dead so this idea
of interactions between superpositions
of different states is one of the key
components of quantum computing and it's
not something that you can do
classically with bits ones and zeroes as
Adam mentioned classical computers
involve
a whole series of ons and offs and then
they can interact together with one on
turns another one off there's another
one on and you can you can build
classical math with this you can sort of
add things by representing numbers in
binary with quantum computers or quantum
computing you can do something slightly
more complex which is you can have
switches that are both on and off
simultaneously and intertwined in a way
that once you finally look at it or
interact with it it gets stabilized and
crystallized in one specific state and I
mean you said something interesting you
said quantum computing allows you to
solve certain problems faster why is
that so there's one that's a set of
problems where quantum computing
essentially gives you a square root
speed-up
so the classical example here is
unstructured search if you have an
unordered list of numbers and you
to find a number in the classical world
like the only thing you can do there is
look through the numbers one by one and
you expect to find what you're looking
for on average in half like the number
of numbers you have now with a quantum
computer somewhat mind-bendingly you can
do it in only a square root of the
number of numbers you have and I have no
good way to give an intuitive
explanation of why that is so but it
involves the way that probabilities
evolve probabilities in the quantum
world are always squared so in a
classical world if you check one number
you expect to love a one over n chance
of having found the one you're looking
for and in a quantum world you get sort
of a 1 over square root of n Joe hunts
each time you look and so in a quantum
world once you've looked at sort of a
square root of n u then you've got a
fraction that's approaching 1 so that
does not and it is important let you
solve exponential problems faster than
exponentially so the square root of 2 to
the N is still an exponential problem
however there is a set of problems where
they're not exponential problems but we
don't or some of them are we don't know
any classical efficient way to solve
them but we do know an efficient way to
solve them on quantum computers and the
effects there is much bigger than a
square root it's going from a small
exponent say - just a polynomial and so
for these problems quantum computers
make a huge difference and unfortunately
that set of problems includes sort of
all the problems on which we base public
key cryptography on today so and that
gets to parlors where we wanted to do
this discussion was because we know
quantum computing is becoming more
mainstream in terms that people are
aware of it and then they hear well
that's going to break all the codes once
we've achieved it so the question on
many people's minds is you know what are
the security issues what's the reality
of quantum computer yeah so one thing
that people think about when you talk
about quantum computing is wow you have
all these bits and you can do sort of
infinite number of things together at
once and compute these massively
difficult problems that you can't
normally do this actually is not the
case quantum computing is useful for
speeding up a very small set of problems
one of which is searching through an
onward list other ones would be
simulating quantum interactions so if
you're if you're in physics and you want
to understand how different photons
interact together quantum computing is
an interesting way to simulate that and
the other one is interestingly enough
factoring numbers so if you have a
number and you want to know what the
prime factors are what quantum computers
allow you to do via an algorithm called
Shor's algorithm we don't have to go
into it but it allows you to take a big
number and find out what its prime
factors are quickly it also is useful
for you know related problems around
that field but the interesting part is
that factoring numbers and being able to
do what's called a discrete logarithm
which is almost equivalent to factoring
numbers lets you break almost all modern
cryptography you have a big enough
quantum computer that has enough bits
that you can intertwine together you can
actually take any modern cryptographic
algorithm that we use and figure out
what the key is so this is somewhat
scary you could say to how we
communicate online and how we share
information cryptography is is pervasive
if you're accessing Gmail or you're
accessing any sort of website on the
internet or sending chats to your
friends we use modern cryptography all
the time for this so with a sufficiently
large quantum computer there's risks
that this cryptography can be undone so
should we be panicking about security no
I'm pretty much trying to lead to that
so don't panic
there may be a deep reason why quantum
computing causes are so many problems
we've based our cryptography on problems
that we don't have enough structure to
solve efficiently with classical
computers but they have enough structure
to be quick and to be small and so we've
sort of huddled up against this boundary
of what we could previously solve a
and now quantum computers are moving
that boundary out a little bit
so there's two reasons in which where we
shouldn't panic firstly discussions like
many groups are now building quantum
computers small quantum computers but
quantum computers nonetheless they have
quite high error rates it's very
difficult to build a quantum computer
because the rest of the universe tends
to leak in and cause decoherence and
messes up your quantum states and
everything goes wrong and when that
happens the quantum we do produce the
wrong answer and so the error rates we
have at the moment are quite high we
believe that's given enough quantum bits
with a low enough error rate we can run
error correction codes and so produce
you know a theoretically perfect quantum
bits out of real quantum bits but it
takes a lot of them so it is not the
case that if you see that some group has
you know some quantum computer with some
dozens of bits then once that number
reaches 2048 or some other number you
may have heard of relation to
cryptography that everything is gone and
broken it depends on the technology but
perhaps a hundred thousand or a million
wor qubits to make up just one
functional one is that quantum supremacy
that you're referencing that I've heard
that term before in terms of number of
bits quantum supremacy is it's sort of
an artificial concept quantum supremacy
is the idea that there is an algorithm
out there that a quantum computer can
demonstrably solve faster than a
classical computer and we haven't hit
that point yet and as I mentioned
earlier some of the more interesting
ideas of things that you want to do with
quantum computers involve simulating
physics situations and so the target
that people have for quantum supremacy
is this algorithm called sampling where
you take a lot of bits and you scramble
them up together and they supposedly
represent a certain random but
structured random Association of
probabilities and if you once you
actually look at them they decohere and
you say okay this this fits a specific
distribution whether it's a Gaussian
distribution or Hasaan distribution or
something like that some statistical
representation so the idea is that the
first time that you can get to a point
where a quantum computer can simulate a
random pattern or a random distribution
faster than a classical computer then
it's somewhat supreme there's some type
of supremacy so that's the idea of when
a quantum computer is can be the
classical computer at one specific point
this is not really related to
cryptography these these problems that
people solve with quantum supremacy or
to demonstrate quantum supremacy are
really niche problems that aren't really
applicable to you know breaking modern
cryptography so even if this were to
happen next year or in the next five
years it it wouldn't cause you know the
collapse of our financial system or
everyone to lose their privacy it really
takes a lot more to to find the point in
which cryptography can be broken that's
great to hear it Adam I know you were
saying that the error rate is really
high so that's why this is not as much
of a concern it was there anything else
that you wanted to add around that in
terms of you know why quantum computing
is still sort of far off in the distance
for us for breaking all the codes I mean
I think we've chatted about how how hard
it is to build these quantum computers
and how important it is to consider
error rates and and you know don't just
think that an n-bit 1/2 computer is
going to be able to solve n bit problems
like there's a huge difference between
for physical qubits and the theoretical
qubits that we want to build out of many
many raw ones and the second reason for
don't panic is that I I said that we
have huddled against this border of what
we can solve and how much structure we
put in our problems to make them
efficient we can back away from that
border a bit and we can still have
cryptography that is robust in the face
of a quantum adversary and we don't need
to resort to what is called quantum
cryptography to do that so quantum
cryptography is is putting sort of
expensive boxes of optics on the end of
fiber-optic cables and using quantum
phenomenon to guarantee confidentiality
and so
and that's exciting and interesting but
it's not sort of what Nick and I are
looking at because we're not going to
have you know dedicated for I blocked it
links between everything on the
Internet's we'd like to be able to use
the internet we've got and we can do
that we can use different problems for
public key cryptography that resists
quantum computers and it's just normal
software that runs on normal computers
and runs over the Internet as we know
and love it great well so in terms of
quantum security what are you looking at
what are the things that you're
assessing when you think about long term
what this looks like right now as I
mentioned a lot of cryptography is based
on these number theoretic algorithms
like factoring so RSA this is the
standard way that cryptography has been
done this was the first algorithm for
public key cryptography since 1977 and
RSA involves these numbers that you
scramble up and can encrypt to to
another person and that person can
decrypt it so being able to break this
requires you to factor large numbers
with quantum computers it is potentially
possible to do this so RSA becomes
something that's sort of less safe if
there are large scale quantum computers
and whether that's going to happen in
the next 10 or 15 years we don't really
we don't really know there's sort of
very small quantum computers that are
happening right now but they can't
necessarily break something like RSA so
one thing that we're looking at as Adam
mentioned is different cryptographic
algorithms that are potentially
resistant to the types of things that
quantum computers can do so quantum
computers as we mentioned only have a
few things that they can do better than
classical computers and actualities some
computations are actually worse than
regular classical computers so what
we're looking at right now is finding
algorithms that are resistant to these
quantum computers or that are resistant
to all known quantum algorithms as well
as being resistant to the sort of
classical traditional computers as the
years progressed Computers still get
faster computers get stronger people
we'll figure out better algorithms to
solve classical things so this class of
algorithms to do cryptography that is
resistant to quantum computers is called
post quantum cryptography and many folks
around the world are looking at actually
how to figure out what the right post
quantum cryptography algorithms are and
there are several different
possibilities and different fields of
research and mathematics that have
promising answers for what a quantum
resistant or post quantum cryptography
algorithm would look like and you told
me about NIST which I know is running
this large-scale assessment is it is it
a competition that they're doing the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology
so NIST refer to as a process so NIST is
a US government body which have been
involved in standardizing cryptography
for a long time they standardized sha
and AES and a number of sort of other
acronyms that people would have heard of
if they're paying attention in this
space so they're currently running what
they call a process and they call it a
process to distinguish it from a
competition I think because they expect
to have more than one winner in quotes
ie they will be selecting a portfolio of
possibilities and they have a timeline
that stretches out
I don't recall precisely but some five
or six years from now and so they
invited groups around the world to
submit proposals and at the end of 2017
there were I not sure the quite like
some close to 70 proposals submitted
from different groups for candidate post
quantum algorithms and NIST has
published all of these and so people are
now going through these round one
submissions and breaking some of them
and analyzing others and sort of
whittling them down a little bit and
then that some voidness will publish you
know the shortlist for round two and
that will continue for a few years to
come that's great and in terms of this
process do you use some of the
algorithms that you see coming from NIST
in experiment
with them chrome in 2016 did do an
experiment with one post quantum
algorithm so if you used Chrome in 2016
you may well have used a post quantum
algorithm when connecting to Google
servers and we did that both to raise
the profile of this subject in general
and also to check the viability because
one of the it appears consequences of
post quantum algorithms is that they
will be less efficient either in terms
of speeds or in terms of size and we had
simply you know never tried running a
key agreement algorithm that large over
the Internet and it's the Internet's
very complicated you don't always know
what's going to happen and so we did
this experiment looks at latency impacts
and impacts on error rates and it all
went pretty well
so you actually touched on one small
thing but I'd love to learn more about
like what are the characteristics or the
differences between like what's current
cryptography and like what cryptography
would look like in a post quantum world
cryptography right now uses several
different primitives that provide
different security features there is
symmetric cryptography
this is cryptography in which both
parties already have the same key and
you are making sure that the data is
confidential so that only the person
with the exact same key can decrypt it
it also this is this is symmetric
encryption there's also something called
integrity that you can add on top of
that message authentication codes are
Mac's are one of those and this also
requires symmetric keys so both people
have the exact same key so you can send
information across the internet or
across any kind of untrusted medium as
long as both parties have the same key
you can you can communicate now these
keys nowadays are around 120 bit eight
bits long that's considered to be the
smallest possible key that will give you
a long term amount of security in a post
quantum world because of the square root
level advances in being able to search
through a list the only real difference
is that these keys go from
128 bits to 256 bits so this is
something that we're used to and this is
something that that we can do the the
bigger differences come in these so
called asymmetric algorithms the ideas
of public key encryption RSA that I
mentioned these allow you to as an
individual have a private key as well as
a public key and your public key is
shared with the world and anyone can
encrypt data so that only you can
decrypt it using your public key so you
take data you take the public key you
scramble up the data and only the person
with the associated private key can
decrypt it similarly there's the idea of
digital signatures where you can take
that private key and associated with a
piece of data so that anyone in the
world with your public key can then
verify that only the person with the
private key was able to digitally sign
that data so these both provide ways for
folks to agree on symmetric keys so you
go from public key asymmetric
cryptography to sharing a key and being
able to communicate across the Internet
each one of these different pieces
whether it's symmetric key cryptography
whether it's digital signatures or
public key cryptography has a quantum
resistant post quantum component to it
and as Adam mentioned these typically do
not have the same performance
characteristics in terms of computing so
it's either going to cost a lot more of
CPU to compute these operations so it
might take milliseconds longer than it
would usually or the key sizes are much
bigger and as I mentioned symmetric keys
have 128 bit key size they go up to you
know 256 typically right now for public
key cryptography if you're using
elliptic curves which is very popular
you have 256 bit numbers RSA it's about
2048 bit numbers when you're talking
about post quantum cryptography these
keys can get up into the 10,000 bits
range or
for some disproportion Mis proposals you
can have keys as large as a terabyte how
does one test for quantum computing when
the quantum computers are still in
development so as in theory essentially
it is the case that's all of our
classical cryptography we don't know
that there aren't efficient algorithms
to break it on a classical computer our
only basis for believing that there
aren't is that we've looked real hard
we've never found one and so it remains
with quantum computers so Peter shor was
able to come up with Shor's algorithm
for factoring long before any quantum
computer existed because we know in
theory the physics and so we can
theorize about given this problem can we
come up with a quantum algorithm that
efficiently solves it and if the answer
is no then we you know hypothesize that
it is post quantum secure but just like
classical cryptography we have knows of
proof that there isn't an efficient
algorithm out there that nobody's just
found yet but that's a situation we're
relatively comfortable with because it's
always been that way interesting you had
listed that you're interested in diving
into a little bit as what is the
difference between confidentiality
versus authenticity so this is also a
very important point when speaking about
the different types of things that
cryptography provides I mentioned
symmetric cryptography is sending a
message and making sure that only the
person that it's intended for can
decrypt it this is confidentiality this
is how you keep your information
confidential the other piece is
integrity which is how do you make sure
that someone didn't change that message
even if they didn't see what it was how
are you sure that this message is in the
right order that it's it's exactly the
message that the person sent and in a
scenario where somebody is trying to
attack your cryptography these have
different timelines so if you have the
ability to break an integrity algorithm
if someone's already sent the message
that doesn't really help you if
someone's already received the message
that it doesn't help you at all because
the message is sent it's been received
it's been it's been checked
so if you have the ability to break
integrity you have to be there right now
and intercepting communication and
changing it and modifying it before it
gets to the person that you're talking
to when it comes to confidentiality you
have to be prepared for attackers in the
future so if you're communicating with
someone right now and saying something
that you want to be secure for 30 years
then and you're sending it over an
insecure Channel then you want to make
sure that the confidentiality algorithm
that you're using is going to be able to
not be broken for those 30 years so
sometime in the future if someone's
collected it they break that algorithm
they can you know reveal what it is you
said and this is actually the more
pressing point for quantum cryptography
if we're talking right now about digital
signatures it's not so important that we
get a digital signature right now with
respect to quantum security because in
the next five years of the next ten
years there's not going to be a
large-scale quantum computer but in the
next 25 years of the next thirty years
there's potentially a chance you know
technology moves rather quickly and
twenty five years is a long time so the
main focus of what the chromes
experiment was and and what we're
looking at right now for post quantum
cryptography is how do we do this key
agreement how do we make sure that the
confidentiality of communication is
actually quantum resistant so having a
post quantum key agreement algorithm is
very very important now because
everything that you say on the internet
although encrypted right now in the
future with the quantum computer you
know someone should should be able to
eventually decrypt it if they have a
copy so I'm just gonna have one point to
that which is that when we do these
experiments with post quantum algorithms
going back to how I said that we have no
proof of security for them or the
cryptography we currently use so we
combine them because it's quite possible
that
suppose if post quantum algorithm might
not only fall to a quantum computer it
may fall to a classical computer and so
when we add them we will we don't
replace the current cryptography with
all men set and run both and then mix
the outputs together so that the
combination is as strong as the weakest
of the two and therefore at least by
using a supposedly close quantum
algorithm we're at least not making
things any worse is there any specific
resources or places that you'd recommend
if people are interested in better
understanding post quantum security post
quantum cryptography outside of NIST I
mean there are various websites for
cutting-edge research there's an annual
conference called the PQ crypto
conference and this is where the latest
and greatest from the academic research
comes out but a lot of this is is very
very new and very ongoing and it's
rapidly changing so every year something
that was considered to be post quantum
secure last year gets broken and this is
especially true with the NIST process so
there's there's a number of websites and
and resources for getting up-to-date
with post quantum cryptography but I
think waiting for the end of the NIST
competition / process to happen is
probably probably where people want to
get more involved and more more
interested in this because otherwise you
may be overwhelmed with the the rapid
rate of change I think this is a
resource that someone needs to build is
an accessible list of links about
joining the post quantum I know there's
there's one website Adam on his website
I wrote an introduction on on lattice
based once upon a time it's a bit narrow
though well look for that and speaking
of the post quantum crypto conference my
understanding is that was last week Nick
were you at that conference yeah I made
it to the post quantum conference last
week and we saw a bunch of interesting
proposals that kind of moved the state
of the art even more past the algorithms
that were submitted to the Miss contest
which is kind of surprising but
not it was even less than half a year
ago that the final proposals were due
for the nist process but several of them
have been broken in interesting ways
some of them have been modified in
interesting ways and there's even
brand-new proposals that have yet to be
crypt analyzed so when you talk about
what the new standards are gonna be for
post quantum cryptography I think what
comes through the first miss processes
are not going to be the final ones that
that people use I think there's just so
many different arenas of research so
active right now that we'll be
discovering new algorithms for a long
time going forward and from an
implementers point of view this is
perhaps frustrating right because you
want to pick a standard and stick to it
and make sure that people have
implemented it correctly and safely I'm
looking forward to more cryptography
that's oriented towards safe and secure
implementation and deployment as well as
you know security against quantum
machines anything specific that comes to
your mind that you were most excited to
see or you found most interesting from
that conference the main thing that
resonated with me was the diversity of
types of mathematics that were involved
so a field of cryptography that I hadn't
studied very much is called code based
cryptography and this uses things like
error correcting codes to build crypto
systems so rather than using
mathematical properties like prime
numbers and whatnot it uses these codes
that are used in communication and you
can build crypto systems on this and in
fact one of the first quantum resistant
algorithms is based on this type of
thing so there's there's cryptography
everywhere you can kind of build
interesting crypto systems from a lot of
different arenas and it's it's just it's
just fascinating to see it all evolve
and sort of tumble together so code base
cryptography is perhaps has some issues
where you you have encryption failures
once in a while so you have these modes
in which cryptography as you're used to
it is supposed to work one
percent of the time you lose that in
some of these new constructions so I
think some of what is most interesting
to me is cryptographic algorithms that
most closely represent the intuition
that we have from current cryptography
and that helped fit into our current
system so that people can actually
deploy them and make use of them on the
Internet is there something you think
would be great if we could bring these
types of insights or these types of
expertise that could potentially help
expand post quantum cryptography
research one of the things I would like
to see with post quantum would be some
lessons learned from earlier
cryptography a lot of the cryptography
we use today was developed and
standardized in the 1990s and I think
there were some things that has a world
we just got wrong there we made things
that were overly complicated and overly
configurable and difficult to implement
correctly and the consequences of VAS
have have not been good right the
consequences of those problems are bulks
and security issues and so I think we
are now a lot better at recognizing
these issues and recognizing you know
what is the extensible level of
complexity and what are the errors that
implementations are likely to make and
then we will think about how do we
structure these designs to avoid these
errors and so while I think we're better
I would like most like to see post
quantum cryptography really embracing
that more practical concern but that has
to come down the road in some cases
because we are still at the theoretical
point in many of these algorithms they
are still and development and in some
cases quite rapid evolution but if we
didn't repeat the mistakes of the past
in the next cycle that would be that'd
be very nice
Adam Nick we we're definitely running
out of time unfortunately as much as
this a great conversation so I'd like to
say thank you to you both for spending
time with us
and talking about positive quantum
security and quantum cryptography you're
very welcome
yes thank you both and just to give you
a chance it was there any last things
that you wanted to plug keep an eye on
the space
and folks will be exploring these
quantum allegorical turn resistant
algorithms more and more in the coming
years and don't panic
landfill thank you so much thank you
again well thank you Adam and Nic that
was very insightful we really appreciate
you coming on the show to talk to us
about quantum security I know I actually
have like a bit of an idea of what those
words mean that's fabulous yeah I did
that no idea now we will quiz you it's
electric
alright so mark the question of the week
so you've been coding in real time and
streaming this coding experience how do
you do that if you wanted to do that one
would want to do one would want to do
this not related to Google cloud at all
but possibly still interesting so it's
actually really fun and really cool and
I really like doing it and is remarkably
simple you can find all sorts of really
great resources on the internet and in
fact I will link to a particular blog
post that I first read that I found
particularly useful by someone I'm going
to probably mess up their name Susie
Hinton she wrote a blog post called
lessons from my first year of live
coding on Twitch where they took all the
way through the tools and how they do it
I pretty much lifted that and spoke to
us on my teammates about how they do it
but the short answer is so I've been
streaming a garnish development so doing
stuff with kubernetes basically on
twitch so twitch is really easy to set
up you can go there twitch.tv and just
give a count but the real two pieces to
this one is getting yourself a decent
microphone so you have good audio doing
it on your laptop Pat don't do that blue
Yeti will do in a pinch
Road podcasters are really nice as well
I've been using the ones we have that a
nice expensive mics from the podcast so
I get advantage of that but the other
thing that you should use that's really
awesome is a piece of open-source
software called OBS studio runs on
Windows Mac Linux pretty much everyone
uses it it's kind of amazing actually
what it does you can do sort of
picture-in-picture you can put your
webcam in one spot something else in
another switch between scenes so like
I'll show you a picture of my dog while
I'm waiting for to get the stream
started and then switched to me and that
kind of stuff and it'll record locally
and that kind of thing too so that you
can push that video up to youtube or
anything like that it's OBS studio isn't
magic it's it's really amazing but yeah
other than that get yourself on Twitch
write some code try and do it on a
regular basis and it's pretty easy get
started and if you have any counts that
you're working off of I know one of the
things we were talking about is how you
should probably create a fake account to
use while you
you're coding to show everything tsunami
you're not showing your account slash
your passwords or anything like that if
possible so consider that also yeah if
you run like a clipboard like a
clipboard manager of any kind just clear
that out before you start that kind of
stuff you could you can go as far as
like starting a whole new like browser
profile and that kind of stuff may not
do that you've heard it here first folks
coding and and we should add the link to
you where your live coding as well yeah
yeah we should definitely put that in
there it's so mark if anybody wanted to
get in touch with us how would they do
that that is a great question we haven't
done this in a while
yes cool alright so let's go through the
things if they want to email us they
would email us at hello at GCP podcast
calm yep if they want to reach out to us
on reddit it slash are slash DCP podcast
if they want to tweet at us we're at GCP
podcast if they want to reach out to us
on google+ it's plus gcd podcast and
we're on slack and you can request an
invite to the google cloud select
community and join the hashtag podcast
channel bitly / g CP - slack marking
you're going anywhere anytime soon I
really am NOT
you were like flattened by the now
you're just like last year's really busy
you're just I don't know it's gonna be
fine
but yeah you can find me on Twitch I'm
on there I'll be regularly streaming at
9 a.m. on Tuesdays but follow me on
Twitter on Twitch so you can find other
stuff I'm doing nice myself I'm not
going anywhere else for the rest of the
month so I'll be around cool guest means
we get to hang out more
oh no we do have a lot of interviews
coming up all right well Melanie thank
you very much for joining me for yet
another way thank you and thank you all
for listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]